I think there's definitely resentment I
think that you know if we if Luxor comes
back it's gonna be you know it's not
gonna be nice
she broke her heart you know they tend
not to let us do too many I mean like
Ricky and Bob definitely do most of
their own like they're big strong guys
me they I mean I've had like so many
injuries that they're just like okay you
know what we're just gonna let this
stunt double take this one but it's
great fun like I've learned how to do so
many like amazing things and ride horses
and shoot guns
fight like yeah it's right but it is
yeah I think it's I think it's it's
important to do as much scan yeah I'm
not sure what they're gonna do with that
because I mean the this crazy how how
much people have responded to that you
know
but yeah I mean I like I think we might
have obtained not necessarily
romantically but you know otherwise so
you know it'd be nice to see them find
each other again I just wanted to work
with best peers so that was cool like I
can actually say I'm a really good
kisser now like I had something to prove
it yeah I didn't know I I think it's
pretty amazing like but I get to play
this out like and I was really shocked
to hear that it that I'm one of the
first to do do that like it's just
craziness to me but anyway it's great I
think that
but like playing like something so far
in the future we get to forget about
sexuality race you know all of those
stupid things that people in our labels
like they're annoying labels which is
which is pretty pretty amazing yeah yeah
I think Mount weather
I think the seeing all those bodies and
knowing that she was responsible for it
I think that was like breaking point
and that was a very intense scene to
film we had like a hundred extras all
leg listed so yeah I think that that was
definitely the most crushing yeah it's
amazing and it can be it can be quite
grueling at times because you know I
don't know there's been a few scenes
that have really been quite disturbing
to shoot like in season one I think in
episode 11 a slasher rounders throat and
like what like watch him die oh my god
I'm like when I watch that was like most
quickly so yeah very intense yeah
you